we got this from The New York Times ABC
News cancels GOP debate after Haley
demands Trump appear to Nicki Haley said
she would not agree to more debates
unless Donald Trump was on stage with
her another debate on CNN was in doubt
before the New Hampshire primary next
week I just I think it's funny there's
no primary no like this this is not a
primary okay this is something weird
Nikki Haley is not even going to debate
Ronda santis why are either of them
running after Trump won with a historic
blowout landslide in Iowa it was a
landslide was 30 points that's the
biggest ever I think the the other the
past record was 12 12% yet Trump's going
to win everybody's wasting their time
however what do we get from what was it
I think MSNBC said I think it was Joy
Reed she's like you know Iowa is all
white Christians so they're of course
going to swing for Trump I think they're
laying out their plan for Nikki haly she
is Hillary Clinton she is this is the
election the primary is the general the
general is meaningless we were
speculating for a long time about how
they're going to get rid of Joe Biden
and I'll say we were correct Joe Biden
is not their nominee Nikki Haley is the
election is happening right now and when
the primaries go to California Illinois
and New York all of these Urban Liberals
are going to show up as Republicans to
vote for Nikki Haley yeah well a lot of
Democrats have been giving money to
Nikki Haley and we've seen that we've
seen Nikki Haley donors bragging
essentially about how Nikki Haley gets
all of this Democrat money and all
really happy about it and also you had
Joy Reed um who yeah we like my social
media team last night was checking out
Joy Reid as well and she was she was
saying that Joy Reed lost because of
racism so lost because of racism yeah
yeah she's brown lady apparently so
they're already embracing her with their
stupid ethos well I I got a question
real quick just uh does Nikki Haley
appear on the ballots as nimada or Nikki
that's question Nikki it's Nikki
yeah I think one of interesting things
oh go ahead I said like a few months ago
I said to a small I said why don't you
host the debate they said the GOP wants
like a million bucks I said what is this
a money-making scheme so they want to
they the GOP the national company wants
to take a ton of money from the outlets
then they want the donors to pay they
invite all donors to sit in so I feel
like this whole thing's just a
money-making scheme yeah that's all
basically is this is their biggest money
generating time period I would assume an
election year the the problem is that
basically the system they have built
doesn't work in this case I mean I was
watching CBS last night when they were
doing all of the election coverage and
they immediately went into can you
believe that despite all these
self-inflicted wounds that Trump has
incurred you know skipping the debate he
is still managing to win which by the
way was completely predicted I mean they
they do not want him to be the nominee
so badly but it's just at this point
impossible to deny instead of adapting
to the current reality they're trying to
say he is he is unpredictable and we
don't know how this would happen the
only person that shocked us was Vic I
mean he wrote from Zer to eight right he
was a Wonder K he amazing spokesperson
but if we all sat here a year ago the
results would have been the same yeah we
wasted a year and we gave aund and
something million dollars you could have
done so much with that money well I I
will say I mean I don't know where Nikki
is NE necessarily spending all of her
money but if any of it is going to
Republicans is kind of funny to hear
that Democrats are giving money to
Republicans for Republican causes I mean
she okay she has spent a ton of money
but it was specifically in Iowa and then
in New Hampshire she hasn't spent very
much Nationwide I'll pull the the
numbers in a second from the ad impact
report but you know she was trying
really hard to have an early Victory
with Iowa she didn't succeed in fact she
didn't even win the race for second
place uh despite what she said this is
now what did she say this is now it's
clearly a two-person race Now sort of
like I don't think you understand well
she thinks it's a two person race
between her and Biden right ah but
probably not considering she didn't even
make it to Second I got to I got to play
this clip for you guys okay can we pull
this we can pull this one up I'd like
you to listen to
this I can safely say tonight IA made
this Republican primary a twers
race I despise this woman but this is
like this is like an episode of vep
because as she's saying this at the
bottom of the screen it shows Trump and
Dan santis in the top two positions and
not her yeah 95% in it's like it's
almost like Curb Your Enthusiasm more
vep she's just so oblivious to the fact
that she lost she's the meme of the guy
cheering and spraying the champagne and
biting the the medal and then he's in
third place and it's like you lost lady
somewhere along the line we started
giving out trophies to second place to
third place to make kids feel good in
high school and Elementary School this
is this is like Nikki giving herself a
trophy after she lost to be to be fair
to be fair we do give first second and
third place because in the Olympics
you've got thousands or millions of
people but when the race is literally
four people you don't get a medal for
coming in bottom 50% technically it was
five because as we as I found out today
ASA Hutchins was in fact there he was
yeah he got 191 votes and then said I'm
out I'm his quote was I am driving back
to Arkansas did you see though there was
a guy who there was well he was running
a presidential campaign even though none
of us realized it I feel bad for him did
you see there was a someone went up to D
santis the other day and gave him a
participation trophy I did see that it
was a nice little viral clip it was cute
it's very nice of them wasn't it yeah
cuz I mean that's really all he's going
to get in the end the thing about he
burned down his career for what for what
and you know the thing the thing that
drives me nuts is that I feel like he
could have been a good candidate and he
had such a poor team his team is
spiteful and mean and exclusionary and
you know like they don't they don't do
anything good for him when we say that V
is running the campaign we hoped Ron de
s d santis would you look now at VI
hugging Donald Trump on stage at a rally
while they chant VP and it's like I'm
just imagining Ron is outside at the
window looking in with like a single
tear rolling down his cheek like that
could be and it's cold the wind more Vi
embraced his youth he embraced the fact
that he was uh you know doing all kinds
of podcasts he he took the New Media
route there were a lot of things that I
think D Santos's team maybe failed to
advise him correctly on and you know
presenting this young fresh image was
one of them it seemed to me like he sort
of became more buttoned up and closed
off as his cign progress and it's
difficult to opportunties right whereas
V has really presented himself in this
beautiful open communicative light which
I think is what people want especially
from Young candidates I mean they are
similar ages they have similar age
children and yet they they seem very
different seem so different there was
such a cool thing the other day it was
like a it was a compare contrast you had
how VI hand handled a Heckler and how
DeSantis handled a Heckler and VI was
like right this was amazing VI always so
uh uh on on Wednesday when we did this
town hall the timcast team was like they
come to me and they go we asked everyone
who's coming to the show to write down a
question and then we're going to go
through them and figure out which ones
are good I'm like no that sounds
terrible I was like we don't want to do
that like that's like cor corporate
garbage and they're like yeah but
someone's going to scream something
crazy and I'm like I'm pretty sure V
will say no he will not accept that and
I was like I don't think we do that I
think it's good they prepared questions
but we're going to call him at random
and so I told V hey my team I don't know
what you what your policy is but my team
had everybody draft questions goes we I
never it's my policy to take no screened
questions let them ask whatever they
want there's viral video of Ronda santis
throwing people out of his events who
said nothing right just cuz he's scared
of of who they may be associated with
right yeah yeah there was a guy the
other day in a wheelchair in yeah in a
wheelchair and so you had you had VI
gets this Heckler the woman starts
screaming something about climate change
and he's like how about this I'll make
you a deal I'll hand you the microphone
for 60 seconds you make your case and
then I'll you know then I'll talk about
it as well yeah I'll tell you why you're
wrong and it was it was a great moment
she was confused she made a terrible
case he was able to trounce it in a
second and then there was a clip of Dan
santis dealing with a Heckler being like
no I'm doing this I'm doing this you
know no no respect no consideration at
all just sort of you know like musling
his way past the guy it was it was
really distasteful I want to go back to
March of 2020 when I think I went to the
last fundraise that Trump hosted for
disantis it was that Mar logo somebody
got Co one of the chefs so they they
still went ahead with the fundraiser but
it was closed was about 80 people these
F these colleagues old colleagues and
friends I had from Long Island they
hosted it for dis Santos March of 2021
so he's he was just it was still a year
to go running for a second term I go in
there I'm with my Dad I'm with other
friends I I run up to very close to the
go I'm trying to talk to them I'm
getting nothing out of him doing my best
I just moved here from New York it's
terrible the policies I couldn't get
anything out of him that I remember
if you meet the sitting governor who's
doing a great job and trying to get a
conversation and nothing's coming out of
him no personality which you can
remember what do we have memories in
life and I can't remember talking to the
governor because nothing came out of him
Trump is there he sees my dad he's had a
clear dis is that your dad he says get
him over here I want to take some photos
and talk to them that sums up the
difference in that little in that little
you know moment in time and that Trump
held his last fundraiser for Des santis
that that sticks out that kind of sums
up the personality I'll tell you uh the
first story I've ever heard of Donald
Trump outside of like the media I was in
Chicago and I met this guy who was a
music producer young guy like you know
college music producer and he said that
he was uh I think he was doing some kind
of delivery when he's going to Trump
Tower to drop off some a package or
something Donald Trump is coming up
behind him as he's walking in and he
holds the door open for Trump and his
team as is walking in and then he walks
in behind him Trump stops and goes hey
kid thanks and he throws him an iPod
this is bad back in the day when iPods
were like several hundred and it meant
something but the kid caught it and he
was like whoa like I held the door over
this guy give me you hear I hear stories
like that all the time where Trump stops
to make sure he leaves you with a
positive impact when I went to Trump
Tower during his campaign cycle in
2015 I was with uh uh some colleagues
and I was like Hey we're you know we're
covering Trump's rallies we're covering
Trump let's go see what his employees
have to say about him so we decided to
get food at the uh Trump steakhous asked
everybody what they thought of trump
they love the guy they love him I went
to he has an ice cream shop downstairs
and I asked him and the people working
there said Trump will show up randomly
and walk call call all the staff out and
just hand everyone $100 bills and
everyone's like we're so excited when
Trump comes he's such a nice guy shakes
everybody's hands thanks them for their
work and then gives them $100 to be fair
Tim does this too we'll just gather
around staff meeting hands up staff
meeting here's money no I'm just kidding
Tim doesn't do that no we play poker I
take the money from you and Tim just
like s and stuff it's fine no but I I
think that's true Trump had that
personality and it stayed true when he
was president I mean the presidency I
could see potentially you dial it back a
little bit you have to whatever my one
of my favorite clips of trump ever is
when he and Melania my favorite first
lady were handing out um Halloween candy
and someone comes up in like a Minion's
costume he like puts this fullsize
chocar in this kid's head and he's
obviously laughing like there was
something pull that up please do it's my
f one of my favorite Trump clips of all
time there is something you know he's
Brash there are times you don't like him
whatever there is such a personality
that is true and authentic there that
you kind of laugh along with him last
night here we go can we just can we just
play this real quick cuz it's like it's
the best one of the best clips of trump
ever there's little spider two two
Spider-Mans and a unicorn princess M
here comes the look the kids hands he
can't reach his
head they both put candy on and then
they that's amazing they slide off and
fall in a little girl's bag and and it's
Melania who's like well I'll give you
another one like hold on don't leave yo
that is one of the best moments ever
funny look at him he like test it out
make sure it doesn't hurt him and then
look it slides off the head and lands
right in the girl's bag oh no they fell
on the floor they fell on the floor
that's why she gives her another one
then someone comes and picks them up oh
my God the kid in the minion's costume
is arms can't reach above his head it's
it's just these small things or there's
another one where he's on the phone we
don't have to play this CP they're
taking calls from kids around Christmas
and there's one where he's like uh you
know wishing it he's like how old are
you seven Merry Christmas so you on
Santa that's right on the edge like
where are we like he just has the
personality that shines through and I
think so many Americans like that
because it's not stiff and formal I
worry I think you know I think Ronda
Sanz could have a political future I'm
not one to speculate what it could be
but you know it it's sort of embracing
that personal connection that people are
really craving in this day and age and
it has so much to do with our our
personal interactions with our neighbors
falling apart to see a presentent that
you can all kind of share these memories
with and laugh like that's something
people desperately want and the
politicians that can do that like Trump
like vake Thrive I made it the Heartland
proved last night they love a funny
Brash fighter New Yorker right and
that's we proved it again last night and
the culture Hollywood the media used to
love Trump until until three four nine
years ago until he decided to say I'm a
republican I'm running for office all of
a sudden he wasn't well he was great for
headlines right he's still great for
headlines still great for headlines but
it's negative headlines it used to be
all positive Trump was a you know an
icon in New York he did so many
wonderful things building this skat and
rink he paid for Jesse Jackson's office
for the Rainbow Coalition oh really yeah
back in the day inter I didn't know that
I know thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net